今日は何の日ってわかるか
そう、今日は五月五日、こどもの日なんだけれどもううううーー
おい！こども
お前ら五月五日だからと言ってな
大人がな、何でも買ってもらうと思うなよ
こどもの日だからってな
大人はな、お前らにお金をあげたりな、おもちゃをあげる日じゃないんだよ！
お前たち、おもちゃが欲しかったら
自分でゲットしろ！
それが、社会の仕組み
今日はね、パパとママにおもちゃを買ってもらったんだ　～ヾ(´︶`*)ﾉ♬
わあああ〜〜
ええええ、Air hogs ATMOSPHERE！
。。。
アァァ〜パパママありがとう
アァァー楽しみだ！おもちゃだ、おもちゃ！
パパママありがとう
なんかこれはね、あのね
わかんないけど飛びそうだったから買ってもらったんだ
イタッ
アァー　イタッ、痛いよ
アァー　パパママに買ってもらった
大事にしようっと　(*´∀`)~♥
うあっ、やべー
浮くらしいですよこれが
あの冗談ですよ、パパママに買ってもらってませんからね
自分のお金で買いましたから
もう僕も21歳なんで
こどもの日には、昔はね、こどもの日にはなんかもらってた気がするんですけど
僕も大人なんでね
何ももらえないんです
一応こんな感じなんですけど
わからないぞ
これ説明書を読んだほうがいいパターンですね
全部英語じゃん〜
ドライバーでこっちに電池を入れなきゃいけないんで
入れます〜〜
アァー
オォー
おし、できたっ
うおー
飛ぶものになんか惹かれるんですよね
なんでだろう
どうすればいいんだ
これでいいの？
えっ
これで充電するっぽいですね
ちょっ　わかんない
うあー痛い！！
なるほど
だから回転することっすね
くそー　いきなり殺傷ーされたよ
よしっ、
危ないこれ
なるほどね、 こういう
こういうことね
うあー　イタっ、痛い！
やべっ、これ死ぬわ、これ死ぬほど痛いTT
なるほど。このランプが緑になったら充電完了らしいです
ちょっと緑まで、遊んでいきますー
というわけで、
完璧だな
緑色になったのでね、もうたぶんいけると思いますー
これがたぶんフルパワーだから
なかったら僕のこどもの日はもう終わりですよ
これだ！
どう、どうよ( • ̀ω•́ )
ということで、ぜひね
皆さんも、
買ってみたらいいと思いますこれ
じゃな